Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the 27th of January 1848, Alexei de Tocqueville, French aristocrat and probably best known in the English-speaking world as the author of a groundbreaking study of democracy in America, addressed the Chamber of Deputies in Paris, and I will quote, Do you not feel, by some intuitive instinct which is not capable of analysis, but which is undeniable, that the earth is quaking once again in Europe? Do you not feel, what shall I say, as if a gale of revolution were in the air? This gale, no one knows where it springs from,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。如需每周独家特辑、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1848年1月27日，法国贵族阿列克谢·德·托克维尔——在英语世界里，他或许最为人所知的身份是那部关于美洲民主的开创性研究的作者——在巴黎众议院发表了演讲，我在此引用他的话：“难道你们没有通过某种无法分析却不可否认的直觉，感觉到欧洲的大地再次在颤抖吗？难道你们没有感觉到，该怎么说呢，仿佛有一股革命的风暴正在空气中酝酿？这股风暴，没有人知道它从何而起，
whence it blows, nor, believe me, whom it will carry with it. Can you say today that you are certain of tomorrow? Do you know what may happen in France a year from now, or even a month or a day from now? You do not know. But what you must know is that a tempest is looming on the horizon, that it is coming towards us. So, Dominic, momentous words, and as it turns out, prophetic, because that year of 1848 is commemorated as the year of revolutions. The voice of prophecy, Tom, is often all the more resonant
从何处吹来，更请相信我，它会把谁卷走。今天，你们敢说自己对明天充满确信吗？你们知道一年后、甚至一个月后或一天后的法国会发生什么吗？你们不知道。但你们必须知道的是，一场暴风雨正在地平线上隐现，它正向我们袭来。”多米尼克，这些话意义深远，事后证明也具有预言性，因为1848年被人们纪念为革命之年。汤姆，这种预言的声音往往更加响亮，
when it's read out in the voice of Chief Inspector Jacques Clouseau, as that was. I thought you were going to say, in French, the language of diplomacy. No, I wasn't going to say that. But yes, so we welcome Inspector Clouseau to the podcast for this episode about the 1848 revolutions. So yeah, 1848 is remembered as the year of revolutions. And yet, of course, the question is, what was it all for and what did it achieve? Because lots of people listening to this will have a sort of vague idea that 1848 is a bit like 1789 or 1968. It's one of those dates that conjures up images of barricades and people on the streets. But it's more like 1968 though, isn't it? Because actually the revolutions fizzle
就像刚才那样，当它用总督察雅克·克鲁索的声音读出来的时候。我以为你要用法语说，那是外交的语言。不，我没打算这么说。不过，是的，我们欢迎克鲁索督察来到播客，共同探讨1848年革命。所以，是的，1848年被铭记为革命之年。然而，问题当然是，这一切究竟是为了什么，它又取得了什么成就？因为听到这里的许多人会有一种模糊的想法，觉得1848年有点像1789年或1968年。这是那些让人联想起街垒和街头人群的日期之一。但它其实更像1968年，对吧？因为实际上，革命最终不了了之，
out and there's lots of kind of young people rushing around standing on barricades. Yeah. And then lots of people shooting them yes basically basically and so the standard question about 1848 is why does it fail yes why do the revolutions fail however in a groundbreaking study revolutionary spring fighting for a new world 1848 1849 by the great christopher clark who is with us on the show. The Regis Professor of History, Sir Christopher Clarke, Tom. We're very big on titles. Professor Sir Christopher Clarke. And what's more, Tom, I know he's going to speak in a second, but just let me say, we're particularly indebted to Chris for joining us because he's Australian.
有大批年轻人四处奔跑，站在街垒上。是的，然后有很多人开枪打死他们，是的，基本上就是这样。因此，关于1848年的标准问题是，为什么它会失败？是的，为什么革命会失败？然而，在伟大历史学家克里斯托弗·克拉克的开创性研究著作《革命之春：为新世界而战，1848-1849》（Revolutionary Spring: Fighting for a New World 1848-1849）中——他今天也来到了我们的节目中。雷吉斯历史学教授，克里斯托弗·克拉克爵士，汤姆。我们非常看重头衔。克里斯托弗·克拉克爵士。不仅如此，汤姆，我知道他马上就要发言了，但请允许我先说一句，我们特别感谢克里斯加入我们，因为他是澳大利亚人。
And like a lot of people, he'll be in mourning because of the very recent passing of Dame Edna Everidge. Chris, was that a traumatic moment for you when you learned the news? It was a sad moment, I have to say. And I mean that, actually. Oh, my word. I expect nothing less from the Regis Professor of History. She was a very remarkable lady. Yeah. And she spoke for us all. I have to say, I didn't think that we'd be talking about Edna Everidge as our first topic.
和许多人一样，他现在一定沉浸在悲痛之中，因为德姆·埃德娜·埃弗里奇不久前刚刚离世。克里斯，当你得知这个消息时，这是一次痛苦的经历吗？我必须说，这是一个令人悲伤的时刻。而且我是认真的。哦，天哪。我不禁对雷吉斯历史学教授肃然起敬。她是一位非常卓越的女士。是的。她代表了我们所有人的心声。我必须说，我没想到我们会把埃德娜·埃弗里奇当作我们的第一个话题。
Dominic, can I go back to what i was going to say before you do diverted us yeah you're always welcome to do that tom okay so the takeaway i mean there are lots of takeaways from that from this book which is on an absolutely comprehensive scale because the takeaway that i found particularly intriguing is that you basically say that the whole question of did they succeed or fail is a nonsense question. Towards the end of the book, you say, we don't say of an ocean storm, a solar flare, or 16 days of heavy snowfall, that they succeeded or failed. We simply measure their effects. Yeah, I think that the problem with asking whether a revolution failed or succeeded is that, I mean, you might argue that, you know, look, we don't say that about 16 days of heavy snowfall, but that's because snow is a natural phenomenon. Whereas a revolution is
多米尼克，我能回到我刚才想说的话题吗？在你把我们带偏之前。是的，汤姆，你随时都可以这么做。好的，所以我的收获——我的意思是，这本书规模宏大，从中可以有很多收获——我发现特别耐人寻味的一个收获是，你基本上说过，“它们是成功了还是失败了”这个问题本身就是一个伪问题。在书的后半部分，你提到，我们不会对一场海洋风暴、一次太阳耀斑或十六天的暴雪说它们成功了还是失败了。我们只是衡量它们的影响。是的，我认为，问一场革命是失败了还是成功了，其问题在于——我的意思是，你可能会反驳说，“看吧，我们不会对十六天的暴雪这么说”，但那是因为雪是一种自然现象。然而革命却是一个
a political phenomenon driven by a political intention. And so we ought to be able to ask the question, was the intention fulfilled? Is there a match between outcomes and intentions? And if there is, we can say it was a success. And if there isn't, we can say it was a failure. But the problem with that is that a revolution doesn't actually have an intention. It has thousands of intentions. This revolution was not planned in advance. It was very chaotic in the way it unfolded. A lot of entropy was built into the whole process. Groups and people kept seceding from the common enterprise. And so the question, what was the intention driving the revolution, has no answer. There were thousands of potentially conflicting intentions. And so that makes the question, was it a success or not, a problematic question, because for some, it was a huge success. For others, it was a disastrous failure. I mean, people died. They risked their lives. They risked
由政治意图驱动的政治现象。因此，我们应该能够提出这样的问题：意图实现了吗？结果与意图是否一致？如果一致，我们可以说这是一次成功；如果不一致，我们可以说这是一次失败。但问题在于，革命其实并没有一个单一的意图。它有成千上万个意图。这场革命并不是事先计划好的。它的演变过程非常混乱。整个进程中内置了大量的熵。不同的群体和个人不断地从共同的事业中分裂出去。因此，“推动革命的意图是什么”这个问题根本没有答案。当时存在着成千上万个潜在冲突的意图。这使得“它是否成功”成了一个充满问题的问题，因为对某些人来说，这是一次巨大的成功；对另一些人来说，这是一场灾难性的失败。我的意思是，有人付出了生命。他们冒着生命危险，
everything for this revolution. So it makes more sense, it seems to me, to think of the revolution as a process. I mean, I like to think of it as a sort of, as a collision chamber at the heart of the 19th century. Everything fell into this chamber. It got crushed together with everything else under conditions of extreme density and pressure. And then these entities showered out the other end of the process into the rest of the 19th century. But everything was changed. No one was the same shape. No ideas were bent out of shape. Some things disappeared, others appeared. And so that's the way I like to think. I think we should be thinking about this revolution as a kind of engine of change at the heart of the 19th century. So if we go back to the very basics, your book starts with a couple of thematic chapters
为了这场革命赌上了一切。在我看来，把革命视为一个过程要合理得多。我的意思是，我喜欢把它看作是19世纪核心的一个碰撞室。一切都落入这个室中。在极端的密度和压力条件下，它与其它一切事物一起被粉碎在一起。然后，这些实体从这个过程的另一端喷涌而出，进入19世纪的其余时间。但一切都改变了。没有人还是原来的形状。许多想法都被扭曲了。有些事物消失了，另一些事物出现了。这就是我喜欢看待它的方式。我认为我们应该将这场革命视为19世纪核心的一种变革引擎。因此，如果我们回到最基础的问题，你的书开篇有几个主题章节，
where you're talking about kind of poverty in Europe and the condition of people in the cities and people in the countryside and so on and so forth. But so Europe in the 1840s, so this is the first decade of the life of Queen Victoria. Railways are beginning to come in. It's not yet a landscape completely transformed by the telegraph, let's say. So in some ways it feels, if you're living in a little village somewhere in the middle of Poland, well, what's now Poland or France or something, it probably feels like a very sleepy world. But in the cities, there's a tremendous sense of velocity, exchange of ideas, new technology.
你在其中谈到了欧洲的贫困、城市居民和农村居民的状况等等。那么，1840年代的欧洲——这是维多利亚女王统治的头十年。铁路开始出现。它尚未成为一个完全被电报改变面貌的世界，比方说。因此在某些方面，如果你住在波兰中部的一个小村庄里——无论是现在的波兰还是法国之类的地方——它可能感觉是一个非常平静的世界。但在城市里，却有一种极强的速度感、思想交流和新技术。
But Europe in the 1840s, what is it about Europe in the 1840s that makes it? I mean, it's not an ancien regime. So what is it that explains the sort of, why is it a revolutionary tinderbox, as it were? I mean, that's a terrible cliche, but you know what I mean. Well, it's a revolutionary tinderbox for lots of different reasons. I mean, one is the point you've already mentioned that, you know, a lot of people are under very high levels of social and economic stress. And this stress isn't a constant. It sort of pulses.
然而，1840年代的欧洲，究竟是什么让它——我的意思是，它并不是一个旧制度。那么，究竟是什么解释了这种——为什么它就像一个革命的火药桶？我的意思是，这是一个糟糕的陈词滥调，但你懂我的意思。嗯，它之所以成为革命的火药桶，有许多不同的原因。其中之一就是你已经提到的那一点，即许多人正承受着非常高的社会和经济压力。而这种压力并不是恒定的。它是一阵一阵的。
It comes at some moments and then recedes. Because this is a system, it's not that everybody's, that there's a generalized shortage of food. There's plenty of food to go around, but every so often, there are disruptions to the food supply, as indeed we're experiencing again today. That's one of the parallels between then and now. And these short-term disruptions to the food supply can push people in huge numbers over the edge, over the brink of subsistence into real crisis.
它在某些时刻到来，然后又消退。因为这是一个系统，并不是说每个人都面临普遍的食物短缺。有充足的食物可供分配，但每隔一段时间，食物供应就会受到干扰，正如我们今天再次经历的那样。这是当年与现在相似的地方之一。而这些短缺的短期中断，可以将数以万计的人推向边缘，越过生存的边缘，陷入真正的危机。
And this, one of the moments at which this happens is 1846-47. There's a very bad, very cold harvest. The price of grains shoots up. And because most of what most poorer people eat is bread or grain-based food of one kind or another, they can't substitute for it with other foods. They can't just eat chicken instead or cake, as famously Marie Antoinette had once suggested they should do in the context of an earlier revolution the streets. It means there are a lot of, you know, discontented, angry, resentful apprentices, artisans, and so on available in the big cities for a tumult, if a tumult should arise. So that's part of the background. But there's also the fact that this is a continent which is incubating lots of different political movements. I mean, one of the fascinating things about the 1830s and 40s in Europe is the extraordinary political biodiversity. There are several hundred different kinds of socialism. I mean, people talk about socialism, but the term has no fixed meaning. And Marx is around and he's commenting on things in a sort of very brilliant
而发生这种情况的时刻之一就是1846至1847年。当时发生了一场非常糟糕、非常寒冷的收成歉收。粮食价格飙升。而且由于穷人吃的大多是面包或某种基于谷物的食物，他们无法用其他食物来替代。他们不能像玛丽·安托瓦内特在早先一次革命的背景下曾经著名地建议过的那样，在没有面包时干脆改吃鸡肉或蛋糕。这意味着在各大城市里，有大量心怀不满、愤怒、怨恨的学徒、工匠等人，随时准备在动乱爆发时投身其中。这就是背景的一部分。但除此之外，还有一个事实，即这片大陆正在孕育着许多不同的政治运动。我的意思是，1830和1840年代欧洲最迷人的事情之一，就是非凡的政治生物多样性。当时有几百种不同类型的社会主义。我的意思是，人们谈论社会主义，但这个词没有固定的含义。马克思当时也在场，他以一种非常精彩、尖刻、具有论战性且相当偏颇的方式对各种事物发表评论。但马克思主义尚未主导这个社会主义光谱。因此，关于如何过上更好的生活、如何建立一种允许人类繁荣发展的国家秩序等，存在着极其多样化的左翼思考，在最广泛的意义上莫不如此。然后还有许多自由主义。自由主义者是那些希望想方设法在专制结构（如绝对君主制，这在1830和1840年代的欧洲比比皆是）与议会权力之间取得平衡的人。然后还有保守派，他们开始思考如何在面对人人都意识到的这股变革浪潮时，保留旧制度中有价值的东西。我的意思是，连梅特涅也谈到过，他说，我们必须筑起一座水坝来遏制洪水。而在这种表述中，我们已经看到，这个作为欧洲大陆资深政治家、奥地利帝国各个时期的首相或外交大臣的人，甚至他也认识到，存在着这种如河流般流淌的变革，你要么顺应它，要么试图筑坝将其阻挡。每个人都承认它的存在。因此，这是一个每个人都意识到冲突和变革潜力的时代，但人们并不确定如何才能实现这一点。而且在我看来，处于顶层的人看起来并不特别具有压迫性，也谈不上专制。
and mordant and polemical and rather one-sided way. But Marxism has not yet dominated this spectrum of socialism. So an immense diversity of left-wing thinking about, you know, how to live a better life, how to create a form of state order which allows humans to flourish and so on and so forth in the broadest possible sense. And then there are many liberalisms. The liberals are the people who want to somehow balance, you know, authoritarian structures like absolute monarchy, of which there are plenty in Europe in the 1830s and 40s, with the power of parliaments. And then there are conservatives who are starting to think about how you preserve what is valuable about the ancien regime in the face of this tide of change that everyone recognizes is there. I mean, even Mettony speaks of, he says, we must build a dam to contain the flood. And already in that formulation, we see that, you know, this man who's the kind of
并且是以一种尖刻、好辩且相当片面的方式。然而，马克思主义尚未主导这一社会主义光谱。因此，关于如何过上更好的生活、如何创造一种能让人类蓬勃发展的国家秩序等问题，左翼思想存在着巨大的多样性，在最广泛的意义上莫不如此。接着还有许多自由主义。自由主义者是那些希望设法在威权结构（例如绝对君主制，18th世纪30和40年代的欧洲比比皆是）与议会权力之间取得平衡的人。然后是保守派，他们开始思考在人人都意识到的变革浪潮面前，如何保住旧制度中有价值的东西。我的意思是，甚至梅特涅也说过，他说，我们必须筑起一座水坝来遏制洪水。而在这一表述中，我们已经看到，这个作为某种
elder statesman of the continent, the chancellor or the foreign minister at various points in his career of the Austrian empire, even he recognizes that there's this river-like flow of change, which you're either going to swim with or try and dam in and stop. And everybody acknowledges that it's there. So it's a time when everybody recognizes the potential for conflict and change, but people aren't sure about how this can be achieved. And the people who are at the top, to my way of thinking, they don't look peculiarly repressive or indeed authoritarian.
欧洲大陆的资深政治家、在其政治生涯各个阶段担任过奥地利帝国首相或外相的人，甚至他也认识到，这种河水般奔腾的变革浪潮，要么随波逐流，要么试图筑坝阻拦。每个人都承认它的存在。因此，这是一个每个人都认识到冲突与变革潜力的时代，但人们并不确定这该如何实现。而在我看来，处于高位的人们，看起来并不显得特别具有压迫性，也谈不上多专制。
So if you take France, for example, King Louis Philippe, he is famously the kind of bourgeois king. Everybody makes fun of him. They say he looks like a pear. He seems like a nice guy. He's like a sort of middle-class Englishman. He's got Guizot, who I think is his prime minister, isn't he? Who's very civilized, cerebral kind of. Yeah. He wrote over 70 books. Yeah. So if you're casting a film, these are not people who make satisfying, repressive villain, top-hatted villains or something. No, you'd probably choose Tom Hanks to play Louis Philippe, I think, rather than
因此，以法国为例，国王路易·菲利普，他是个出了名的“资产阶级国王”。人人都取笑他。他们说他长得像个梨。他看起来是个好人。他就像一个中产阶级的英国人。他有基佐担任他的首相，对吧？他是一个非常文明、极具理性的那种人。是的。他写了70多本书。是的。所以如果你在为一部电影选角，这些人绝对算不上令人满意的、具有压迫性的反派，比如戴着大礼帽的反派。不，你大概会选择汤姆·汉克斯来扮演路易·菲利普，而不是某个坏蛋。
some bad guy. Right. Absolutely. Yeah. So what is it they are doing wrong, as it were? Well, that's a very good question. Actually, Guizot was not doing a huge amount wrong. It was actually in many ways quite a successful government, as you say it. But it was a government that had managed to wind up in a kind of war with the media. That's one of the problems, that there was this shower, a kind of flood of invective against the monarchy, which denounced the king as corrupt, as disgusting, the image of his face as a pear and so on. It wasn't. It sounds rather innocent if it's just that rather likable fruit. But in fact, I'm thinking now of a particular cartoon which is widely reprinted when it appeared in the early 1840s, a cartoon which shows a pear
完全正确。是的。那么，他们究竟做错了什么呢？嗯，这是一个很好的问题。其实，基佐并没有做错太多。正如你所说，从许多方面来看，它实际上是一个相当成功的政府。但这是一个不知不觉陷入与媒体之战的政府。问题之一在于，当时有一股针对君主制的恶言攻势——犹如洪水一般，谴责国王是腐败的、令人作呕的，将他的脸画成梨的形状等等。这并不是……如果仅仅是那种相当讨人喜欢的果实，听起来还算相当无害。但事实上，我脑海中现在浮现出了一幅在1840年代初广为重印的特定漫画，漫画显示一个类似梨的对象坐在一件被称为“糖蜜桶”（coque de molasse）的东西顶上，那是一种装满糖蜜的桶。但你必须记住，在法语中，“糖蜜”是排泄物的某种俚语。而它的下方是一把看起来很皇家的椅子。这个可怕的装置本意是指代国王（一个梨形的脑袋、一桶排泄物和一把漂亮的古董椅子）。而一群法国人正围在它周围，带着厌恶的表情傻看着它。这就是当时政权的形象。与此同时，还有一个问题，即在这个君主制的代议制政治中，究竟谁拥有代表权？这是一个君主立宪制国家，这也是最诡异的事情之一。他们在1830年经历过一场革命。他们修改了1814年获得的宪法。因此从这个意义上说，它是一个立宪的、自由主义的秩序。但这部宪法赋予投票权的国民比例还不到2%。这仅限于男性投票权，而且是极其微小的一部分最富裕人口。显而易见，在法国，人们依然对最初的那场革命记忆犹新。1789年革命的记忆、恐怖统治的记忆、拿破仑政权的记忆犹存。因此，法国与革命有着特殊的关联。但1848年的特点在于，它并不局限于法国，而是向外蔓延。事实上，我的意思是，在1848年，最初爆发革命的并不是法国，对吧？是在西西里。是在西西里。事实上，我的意思是，你说法国人脑子里有这场革命。
like object seated on top of a thing called a coque de molasse, a sort of barrel full of molasses. But you have to remember that molasses was the sort of slang word for excrement in French. And underneath it is a royal looking chair. And this horrible contraption is supposed to be the king, you know, a pear-shaped head and a barrel full of excrement and a nice sort of antique chair. And it's being gawped at by a group of French people who are standing around it looking at it disgustedly. That's the sort of image of the regime. And at the same time, there's the problem of who is represented in the representative politics of this monarchy. It is a constitutional monarchy, and that's one of the weird things. They've had a revolution in 1830. They've revised the constitution that they got in 1814. So it is a constitutional, in that sense,
一个像坐在一个叫“可可·德·莫拉斯”（意思是装着糖蜜的桶）的东西上面的物体。但你必须记住，在法语中，“糖蜜”是排泄物的某种俚语。在它下面是一把看起来像王室的椅子。这个可怕的玩意儿据说是国王，你知道的，一个梨形的脑袋、一桶排泄物和一把不错的古董椅子。一群法国人围在它周围，厌恶地看着它。这就是该政权的某种形象。与此同时，在这场君主立宪制的代表政治中，谁代表了人民，这是一个问题。这是一个君主立宪制国家，这也是奇怪的事情之一。他们在1830年经历了一场革命。他们修改了1814年获得的宪法。因此，从这个意义上说，它是一个宪政国家，
a liberal order. But the constitution enfranchises fewer than 2% of the population. This is a male franchise only, but it's a tiny, tiny fragment of the wealthiest. And obviously, in France, there is the memory of the primal revolution. There is the 1789 revolution, the memory of the terror, the memory of the Napoleonic regime. So France is peculiarly associated with revolution. But the thing about 1848 is that it's not confined to France and that it spreads across. In fact, I mean, in 1848, it's not initially France where a revolution breaks out, is it? It's in Sicily. It is in Sicily. In fact, I mean, you say the French had this revolution in their minds.
一个自由的秩序。但宪法赋予投票权的不到人口的2%。这仅限于男性选举权，但也只是最富有的人当中极小极小的一小部分。显然，在法国，人们对最初的革命仍有记忆。有1789年的革命、恐怖统治的记忆、拿破仑政权的记忆。因此，法国与革命有着特殊的联系。但1848年的特点在于它并未局限于法国，而是蔓延开来。事实上，我的意思是，在1848年，最初爆发革命的其实并不是法国，对吧？是在西西里。是在西西里。事实上，我的意思是，你说法国人脑子里有这场革命。
Of course they do. It's playing like an old film at the backs of their heads. But it's doing that right across Europe. I mean, Europeans in general, this is something they have in common. They have a lot in common in this era, perhaps more even than they do today. They have common stories and narratives. And one of these narratives is the narrative of this revolution in France, of its sequence of phases, you know, the liberal revolution followed by the Jacobin terrorist experiment, followed by the directory, followed
他们当然有。它就像一部老电影一样在他们的脑海深处播放。但这不仅发生在法国，而是遍及整个欧洲。我的意思是，欧洲人总体而言，这是他们共同拥有的东西。在这个时代，他们有着很多共同点，甚至可能比今天还要多。他们拥有共同的故事和叙事。而其中一种叙事就是法国这场革命的叙事，关于它的各个发展阶段的叙事——自由主义革命，随后是雅各宾恐怖统治实验，接着是督政府，最后是拿破仑。他们的脑子里都有这个故事。因此，他们都手现成的剧本。但这个剧本并不一定就是革命的处方，因为对革命的记忆同时也是反对革命的论据。例如，那些记得雅各宾恐怖统治的人会说：“让我们不要冒任何风险。”我的意思是，基佐的父亲在他五岁时被处决了。他的父亲在尼姆被断头台处决。他当然记得这一点，这是一段痛苦的记忆。因此，他坚决反对死刑，也反对任何形式的暴力或极端政治实验。所以，他在某种程度上是一个保守派，并在1848年革命爆发时最终下台。但同时，他也深刻地铭记着法国革命，不过他是把它当作一个教训，来告诫人们不要去冒实验的风险。
by Napoleon. They all have that story in their heads. So they all have that script available. But that script isn't necessarily a sort of recipe for revolution, because the memory of revolution is also an argument against revolution. Those who remember the Jacobin Terror, for example, say, let's not take any risks. I mean, Guizot's father was executed when he was five years old. His father was executed by the guillotine in Nîmes. And he remembered that, of course, it was a traumatic memory. And he remained deeply opposed to the death penalty and opposed to violent or extremist political experiments of any kind. So he was a conservative in one way and would fall when the 1848 revolution broke out. But he was also someone who remembered
被拿破仑。他们的脑子里都有那个故事。因此，他们都有那个现成的剧本。但那个剧本不一定就是革命的某种秘方，因为革命的记忆也是反对革命的论据。例如，那些记得雅各宾恐怖统治的人会说，让我们不要冒任何风险。我的意思是，基佐的父亲在他五岁时被处决了。他的父亲在尼姆被断头台处决。当然，他记得那件事，那是一段创伤性的记忆。他仍然坚决反对死刑，反对任何形式的暴力或极端主义政治实验。因此，他在某种程度上是一个保守派，并且在1848年革命爆发时会倒台。但他也是一个记得
very vividly the French Revolution, but he remembered it as a lesson against risking experiments. So when we get to, let's say, the end of 1847, there'd been bad harvests, there'd been food shortages. So to give us, I mean, just to remind people about the map of Europe, you have France, there was no Germany, Germany's fragmented. There's a kind of German confederation, isn't there? Yes, there's a loose confederation of German states called the Deutsche Bund, which consists of 39 sovereign states. Switzerland is still a very loosely confederated state. It's not really a state at all. In fact, the cantons are virtually is still a very loosely confederated state. It's not really a state at all. In fact, the cantons are virtually independent with a very weak government,
那么，当我们来到1847年底时，曾发生过歉收和粮食短缺。为了让我们——我的意思是，为了提醒大家注意欧洲的地图——当时有法国，但没有德国，德国是破碎的。存在着某种德意志邦联，对吧？是的，当时有一个由39个主权国家组成的松散的德国国家邦联，被称为“德意志邦联”（Deutsche Bund）。瑞士当时仍然是一个非常松散的联邦国家。它其实根本算不上一个国家。事实上，各州实际上是各自独立的，政府非常软弱，从一个地方搬到另一个地方。当时没有意大利。意大利北部受奥地利统治。意大利东北部受奥地利统治。伦巴第和威尼斯都在奥地利的控制之下。皮埃蒙特是独立的。然后是教皇国和两西西里王国。
which moves from one place to another. There is no Italy. And North Italy is ruled by Austria. North Eastern Italy is ruled by Austria. Lombardy and Venetia are both under Austrian control. Piedmont is independent. And then you have the Papal States and the Kingdom of the Two Sicilies. Yeah. So that's a crucial thing as well, isn't it? That the Pope is a temporal ruler as well as a spiritual ruler. The Pope has his own state. That's another exotic feature of the European map at this time. And another exotic sort of piece of local color is the kingdom of the two Sicilies in the south,
是的，这也是一个至关重要的因素，对吧？教皇既是世俗统治者，也是精神统治者。教皇有他自己的国家。这是当时欧洲地图上的又一个异国情调特征。而另一个异国情调的本土色彩是南方的两西西里王国，这是一个名字极其怪异的联合体，由西西里岛和意大利南部、教皇国以南的诺曼大陆合并而成。因此，有许多国家已经不复存在了。另一方面，存在着一个过去不存在、现在却存在的国家，那就是波兰。波兰在地图上根本找不到，因为它在18世纪被其三个邻国——普鲁士人、奥地利人和俄国人瓜分了。因此，波兰国不复存在，但波兰民族却真实存在，人们依然保留着曾经身处伟大的波兰-立那铁联邦的记忆。这再次成为了革命的一个因素，因为这些不幸的波兰人将在把革命议程从一个地方带到另一个地方的过程中发挥非常重要的作用。
which is the bizarrely named amalgam of Sicily, the island, and of the Neapolitan mainland of the south of Italy, south of the Papal States. So there are lots of states that don't exist anymore. On the other hand, there is a state that didn't exist and does now, and that's Poland. Poland is nowhere on the map because in the 18th century, it had been partitioned by its three neighboring states, the Prussians, the Austrians, and the Russians. So there's no Polish state, but there is very much a Polish nation with a memory of what it was like to inhabit the great Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth. And that, again, is a factor in the revolution, because these unhappy Poles are going to play a very important role in carrying the agenda of revolution from one place to another.
这就是那个名字怪异的复合体，由西西里岛和意大利南部教皇国以南部的那不勒斯大陆组成。所以有很多国家现在已经不存在了。另一方面，有一个过去不存在但现在存在的国家，那就是波兰。波兰在地图上无处可寻，因为在18世纪，它已被其三个邻国——普鲁士人、奥地利人和俄国人瓜分。因此，没有波兰国，但确实有着浓厚的波兰民族，并且有着对曾经身处伟大的波兰-立陶宛联邦的回忆。这再次成为革命的一个因素，因为这些不幸的波兰人将在把革命议程从一个地方带到另一个地方的过程中发挥非常重要的作用。
And so, Chris, that is one further element. So you've talked about the legacy of the French Revolution and the social pressures, but this is also an age of nationalism. And you have a brilliant description that its effect on the revolutions of 1880 as a whole was like that of heroin on the body and mind of an addict. So that is something that is enhancing the revolutionary spirit, but also turning it into courses that the powers that be don't recognize. Nationalism is the most difficult theme for 1848 because after 1848 happened, the memory of 1848 was processed by the national movements of Italy, Germany, France, and later of Hungary and so on.
因此，克里斯，这又是一个因素。所以你谈到了法国革命的遗产和社会的压力，但这也是一个民族主义的时代。你有一个精彩的描绘，说它对1880年（应为1848年——译者注）整体革命的影响，就像海洛因对瘾君子的身心影响一样。因此，这既增强了革命精神，同时也将其引向了当权者无法识别的轨道。民族主义是1848年最难处理的主题，因为在1848年事件发生之后，1848年的记忆被意大利、德国、法国以及后来的匈牙利等国的民族运动所加工和利用。
And it's still part of the national memory of Hungary where Viktor Orban never fails to mention the struggles for Hungarian freedom in 1848, always distorting them and turning them, obviously, to contemporary objectives. So nationalism is part of what shapes what we remember about 1848. And so we have to think our way past that lens, lensing effect, if you like, and put ourselves in a world where nationalism is present and has a drug-like effect on people, but it's a periodic effect. People can become extremely excited. They wear national clothing when they come together and they see everybody else wearing their red caps or their blue cinched jackets or whatever it is, whether they're Croats or Hungarians or Germans wearing national costume. The effect on people is absolutely overwhelming. The emotional power of these
它至今仍是匈牙利国家记忆的一部分，维克托·欧尔班总是会提及1848年匈牙利争取自由的斗争，并总是歪曲这些历史，显然是为了服务于当下的政治目标。因此，民族主义塑造了我们对1848年的记忆。所以，我们必须超越这种镜头滤镜效应（如果你愿意这么说的话），将自己置身于这样一个世界：民族主义在那里存在，并对人们产生类似毒品的效果，但这是一种周期性的效果。人们会变得极度兴奋。当他们聚在一起时，会穿上民族服装，看到其他人也都戴着红帽子或穿着蓝色的紧身夹克，无论他们是克罗地亚人、匈牙利人还是穿着民族服饰的德国人。这种对人们的影响是绝对压倒性的。这些爱国情感爆发的时刻，其情感力量是非凡的。因此，在某种程度上，它将人们聚集在一起，让他们沉浸在更大的集体自我中。另一方面，它也分化了他们，因为，你知道的，匈牙利人当他们奋起反抗奥地利人时，发现自己不得不面对斯洛伐克人、克罗地亚人和罗马尼亚人的民族运动——这些人是匈牙利王国境内的少数族裔，他们并不希望受一个独立的匈牙利统治，而是宁愿……它伴随着一种错觉，即它是古老的。因此，当人们体验到民族情感时，他们觉得他们继承了中世纪甚至更早时期的某种非常非常古老的东西。古代马扎尔人或诸如此类的人。古代马扎尔人，完全正确。11世纪在多瑙河流域蔓延开来的马扎尔人等等。然而，
moments of patriotic feeling is extraordinary. So in one way, it brings people together and it submerges them in a larger collective self. On the other hand, it also divides them because, you know, the Hungarians, when they rise up against the Austrians, they find themselves dealing with national movements of the Slovaks, the Croats, and the Romanians, people who are minorities within the Kingdom of Hungary who don't wish to be ruled by an independent Hungary, but would rather be it comes with the illusion that it is old. So when people experience national feeling, they feel they're inheriting something from the Middle Ages or even before that, something very, very ancient. Ancient Magyars or whoever it might be. Ancient Magyars, exactly. Magyars spreading out in the 11th century across the Danubian plain and so on. Whereas,
爱国情感的时刻是非同寻常的。因此，在某种程度上，它把人们凝聚在一起，让他们沉浸在一个更大的集体自我中。另一方面，这也分裂了他们，因为匈牙利人在反抗奥地利人时，发现自己要面对斯洛伐克人、克罗地亚人和罗马尼亚人的民族运动，这些人是匈牙利王国境内的少数族裔，他们不希望被一个独立的匈牙利统治，而是宁愿成为……它带有一种它是古老的错觉。因此，当人们体验到民族情感时，他们会觉得自己继承了中世纪甚至更早的事物，一种非常非常古老的事物。古代马扎尔人或其他什么人。古代马扎尔人，正是如此。马扎尔人在11世纪散布到多瑙河平原等等。然而，
in fact, these nationalist experiences are very new. They're created by newspapers and communication networks. And the national clothing people wear is mostly an invented retro style that people have come up with in the 19th century. Like the kilt, Tom. Invented traditions, exactly. I mean, on that topic, you have a wonderful quote by Metternich, the kind of the conservatives, conservative, the Austrian foreign minister to count Rosetzky, who's basically the military commander with responsibility for Austrian possessions in North Italy.
事实上，这些民族主义的体验非常新颖。它们是由报纸和通信网络创造的。人们穿着的民族服装大多是19世纪人们想出来的一种虚构的复古风格。就像苏格兰短裙一样，汤姆。虚构的传统，完全正确。顺便说一句，关于这个话题，梅特涅——这位保守派中的保守派、奥地利外长——写给负责意大利北部奥地利领地的军事指挥官拉德茨基伯爵的一段话非常精彩。
And he's writing in August 1847, so just before the explosion, that if the past imposed great efforts on us, it was at least better than the present. You and I know how to fight against bodies, but against phantoms, material force can achieve nothing. And today we are fighting phantoms everywhere. Is he expressing something that is commonly felt by the elites in this period, that they're aware, of course, of the revolutionary potential because they have the history of the French Revolution, but that the manifestation of it is something strange, new that they don't know how to fight. They don't know how to cope with.
他在1847年8月——也就是大爆发前夕——写道：“如果过去强加给我们巨大的努力，它至少比现在要好。你我都懂得如何与实体作战，但面对幻影，物质力量无能为力。而今天，我们在到处与幻影作战。”他是否表达了当时精英阶层普遍的一种感受：他们当然意识到革命的潜在可能，因为他们拥有法国革命的历史，但这种现象的表现形式却是某种他们不知该如何对抗、不知该如何应付的陌生而崭新的东西。
Yes. And nationalism is a phantom and a terrifying phantom for Metternich because he's a senior politician in a multinational empire. I mean, we would call it multinational now. Nobody would have used that word then. But it's a commonwealth of ethnicities with, you know, 11 or 12 different major languages and many other dialects beside. So, for an empire like that, nationalism is a dissolving poison. It will simply tear the thing apart. And so, you know, he's right to see nationalism as a threat. It's also a threat in another way, and that is that although it may not voice a principled objection to monarchy, nationalists can also be monarchists, nevertheless, nationalism proposes implicitly, at least, that the center of authority, the kind of center of gravity of a population is not its dynasty,
是的。对于梅特涅来说，民族主义是一个幻影，而且是一个可怕的幻影，因为他是多民族帝国的高级政治家。我的意思是，我们现在会称之为多民族。当时没有人会用这个词。但它是一个由各种族组成的联邦，拥有11或12种不同的主要语言，此外还有许多其他方言。因此，对于这样一个帝国而言，民族主义是一种溶解剂，它会彻底撕裂这个国家。所以，他将民族主义视为一种威胁是正确的。它在另一个意义上也是一种威胁，那就是：尽管民族主义可能不会表达出对君主制的原则性反对（民族主义者也可以是君主制的支持者），然而，民族主义至少暗中表明，权力的核心——一个人口的重心——不是它的王朝，
but its ethnic substance. And that means the people. So it's a way of taking power from the crown and placing it in the heart of an ethnic group, which is, of course, disturbing to the holders of traditional power in Europe. So to sort of turn to the narrative, I mean, Tom mentioned that the first sort of flashpoint is actually not in France, but in Sicily, in Palermo. I think one of the things that your account of it does quite brilliantly is to show all the contingencies and all the twists and turns. And France is the big, I mean, France is the big one, isn't it? So that starts in the first weeks of 1848. And it's all to do with banquets, the cancellation of political banquet, a very sort of banal trigger you one would think for a continental wide upsurge of popular enthusiasm.
而是它的种族实体。这意味着人民。因此，这是一种从王室手中夺取权力并将其置于族群核心的方式，这当然会让欧洲传统权力的持有者感到不安。那么，转回到叙事本身，多米尼克提到第一个爆发点实际上不在法国，而是在西西里岛的巴勒莫。我认为你对这段历史的讲述非常精彩的一点，就是展现了所有的偶然性以及所有的曲折变化。而法国是最大的一场——我的意思是，法国是重头戏，对吧？所以它始于1848年的头几周。这一切都与宴会有关，政治宴会的取消，按理说这只是一个非常平庸的导火索，却引发了全欧洲范围内的民众热潮。
One could sort of quip and say, you know, only France would rise up in revolution because of a cancelled banquet. But, you know, it's true, the Parisian revolution is important. But, you know, think about that speech by Tocqueville, which is de Tocqueville, which Tom cited at the beginning, or Inspector Clouseau cited, that, you know, Tocqueville can make this prophecy because he's been reading the papers, and the papers are full of tumults from all over Europe by the end of January, which is when he speaks, the 27th of January. By the end of January, there's news coming up from the south of Italy, from Palermo and from Naples, but also from Switzerland.
人们可以半开玩笑地说：“只有法国才会因为一场被取消的宴会而爆发革命。”但话说回来，巴黎的革命确实很重要。不过，想想托克维尔的那段演讲——也就是汤姆在开头引用的德·托克维尔的话，或者克鲁索督察引用的那些话——托克维尔之所以能做出这个预言，是因为他一直在读报纸。而到了1月底（也就是他发表讲话的1月27日），报纸上已经充满了来自欧洲各地的骚乱新闻。到了1月底，来自意大利南部（巴勒莫和那不勒斯）以及瑞士的消息不断传出。
I mean, Switzerland had already had a civil war in the previous year, the Sonderbundkrieg, as it's called in Switzerland, which creates a modern constitutional state. In fact, it creates a modern constitutional state. In fact, it creates the Switzerland we have today. The modern Switzerland today is born in 1848. So that's already been happening, and it's widely reported in the press. The horizons of press reportage are very much European. They're not siloed in national or regional or territorial silos. They're very much looking to the extent of the continent. And, you know, Tocqueville is drawing on that when he says, you know, this storm that you see now on the horizon is coming for us.
我的意思是，瑞士在前一年已经经历过了一场内战——在瑞士被称为“同盟战争”（Sonderbundkrieg）——这场战争缔造了一个现代宪政国家。事实上，它缔造了我们今天所知道的现代瑞士。今天的现代瑞士诞生于1848年。所以这一切早已发生，并且在媒体上得到了广泛报道。报刊报道的视野是非常欧洲化的。它们并没有被禁锢在国家、区域或领土的狭隘视角中，而是放眼全欧洲大陆。而且，托克维尔在说“你们现在在地平线上看到的这场暴风雨正朝我们袭来”时，正是借鉴了这些背景。
So the contagiousness of these tumults is already recognizable by the time the revolution happens in Paris. And the interesting thing about this, Dominic mentioned the contingent sort of happenstance quality of this. It is odd how virtually every one of these uprisings begins almost kind of by accident. So the one in Palermo starts when a poster appears, which simply says, you know, a few days there's going to be a revolution. Get prepared. Sicilians, rise up.
因此，当巴黎革命爆发时，这些骚乱的传染性已经是显而易见的。而有趣的是，多米尼克之前提到了这种带有偶然性的巧合特质。奇怪的是，几乎每一次起义几乎都是出于偶然开始的。比如巴勒莫的那场起义，起义是由一张海报的出现而引发的，海报上简单写着：“几天后将爆发革命。做好准备吧。西西里人，奋起反抗吧。
Your moment of freedom has arrived. Signed, Comitato Revoluzionario, the Revolutionary Committee. Now, there was no Revolutionary Committee. This whole thing was a prank put up by a guy called Bagnasco. I just thought, I think maybe people will rise up if I put a sheet on a wall. So, he did that. And sure enough, on the day that the revolution had been announced for, everybody did turn up to see what was going to happen. And nothing happened because nothing had been planned, except that the troops had been doubled and tripled throughout Palermo. So there are many more troops than usual. And inevitably, you know, a clash broke out between the people and the
你们获得自由的时刻已经到来。革命委员会（Comitato Revoluzionario）签。”然而，当时根本没有什么革命委员会。这整件事其实只是一个叫巴尼亚斯科（Bagnasco）的人开的一个恶作剧。他当时心想：“也许如果我在墙上贴张纸，人们就会起义。”于是，他就这么做了。果不其然，在宣布爆发革命的那一天，每个人都涌上街头，想看看会发生什么。结果什么也没发生，因为根本没有做任何计划，除了巴勒莫各地的军队被加倍甚至增至三倍之外。因此，那里的军队比平时多得多。不可避免地，民众与军队之间爆发了冲突，
troops. And that was the beginning of the revolution. And something very similar happened in Paris, you know, shots fired and by accident and so on led to a massive upheaval. Lamartine, a French sort of, you know, liberal slash radical politician, very much involved in the February Revolution, said it was almost as if the revolution was engendered by the curiosity of the crowds that had gathered to see if a revolution would happen. But also, as I've heard say in the case of Paris, we were talking about the silent film playing in people's heads, that Louis-Philippe doesn't want to be Louis XVI. As soon as the revolution breaks out, it's precisely because he has the memory of 1789 and what happened afterwards. He's like, okay, I'm out of here. I'm gone. I'm abdicating. He's gone, absolutely.
而这便是革命的开端。巴黎也发生了非常类似的事情，你知道的，因为意外而走火等原因导致了大规模的动乱。拉马丁——一位深度参与二月革命的法国自由派兼激进派政治家——曾说过，这场革命几乎就像是由聚集在一起、想看看是否会发生革命的群众的好奇心所催生出来的。但正如我听说巴黎的情况一样，我们刚才谈到了人们脑海中播放的无声电影：路易·菲利普不想成为路易十六。一旦革命爆发，恰恰是因为他对1789年及之后发生的事情记忆犹新，他才会想：“好吧，我离开这里。我走了。我退位。”他走了，完全是这样。
And he actually didn't need to do it. Is that right? Would that be fair? I suppose. I mean, the main problem was that the French police in Paris, the municipal guards and the mobile guards and the National Guard and the army, in fact, had all been preparing for decades for a conspiratorial revolution organized by underground networks. And so they were going to concentrate on the areas of Paris where the trouble was starting and crush it there. And then, you know, the plan was all organized around the idea of a conspiratorially organized and planned revolution. But what actually happened was more like a societal tsunami. The society threw off the regime and decided it didn't fear the forces of order anymore. And it didn't respect the government anymore. And that's a really dangerous thing. And there was absolutely nothing that Louis Philippe, I mean, at one point, for example, it was impossible to deploy troops in Paris because the crowds were simply too large.
而且他其实本不必这么做。是这样吗？这样说公平吗？我想是的。我的意思是，主要问题在于，巴黎的法国警察——市警卫队、机动卫队、国民自卫军以及军队——实际上几十年来一直在为地下网络组织的阴谋性革命做准备。因此，他们原本打算集中精力在麻烦开始的巴黎地区将其粉碎。所以，整个计划都是围绕着一场以阴谋方式组织和策划的革命来进行的。但实际发生的情况更像是一场社会海啸。整个社会抛弃了旧政权，决定不再畏惧维持秩序的力量，不再尊重政府。这是一件非常危险的事情。路易·菲利普对此完全无能为力——我的意思是，有一次，举个例子，根本无法在巴黎部署军队，因为人群实在太庞大了。
The troops couldn't move through them. So they simply faced a situation that they were not prepared to handle and weren't capable of handling. And quite wisely, Louis-Philippe decided, well, really, my time's up and skedaddled. So France is obviously, as Dominique said, the big one. It's the great monarchy. It's got the history of the French Revolution. Narratives of revolution in France are something that people can comprehend and understand. But what then happens
军队根本无法在人群中穿行。因此，他们面对的是一种他们没有准备好应对、也无力应对的局面。路易·菲利普非常明智地决定：“好吧，我的时间真的到了”，于是开溜了。所以，正如多米尼克所说，法国显然是重头戏。它是伟大的君主国。它拥有法国革命的历史。法国的革命叙事是人们能够理解和领会的。但随后发生的事情是，
is that revolution starts to spread in a cascade effect across Europe. I don't want to frighten people because we're going to have a break in a minute, but this is what you say about this process. From the beginning of March 1848, it becomes impossible to trace the revolutions as a linear sequence from one theatre of turbulence to the next. We enter the fission phase, in which almost simultaneous detonations create complex feedback loops. The narrative bursts its banks. The historian bespares. Oh no. Oh no. So, I think we should take a break at this point. And then when we come back, perhaps you could express why you despair and how you triumphantly overcome your despair and give
革命开始以级联效应在欧洲各地蔓延。我不想吓唬大家，因为我们马上就要休息一下了，但你对这个过程是这样描述的：“从1848年3月初开始，已经不可能将这些革命作为从一个动荡剧场到下一个动荡剧场的线性序列来进行追踪了。我们进入了裂变阶段，几乎同时发生的引爆创造了复杂的反馈循环。叙事冲破了堤岸。历史学家感到绝望。哦，不。哦，不。所以，我想我们应该在这个时候休息一下。等我们回来时，也许你可以解释一下你为什么绝望，以及你是如何凯旋般地克服绝望，并为我们描绘出这种级联效应的。”完全可以。那么我们几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、独家特辑以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。我亲爱的、善良的、挚爱的妻子，再见。好好活着，为了这个被称为永恒实则不然的时代。
us a sense of this cascade effect. Absolutely. So we'll see you back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. My dear, good, beloved wife, farewell. Live well for the times as is called eternal, but is not.
让我们感受到这种级联效应。绝对的。那么我们几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦的必听节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获取额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。我亲爱的、善良的、挚爱的妻子，再见。好好生活，因为这个时代被称为永恒，实则不然。
Bring up our, now only your, children to be fine people. Sell our few possessions with the help of our friends. God and good people will help you. Oh, everything I feel runs away in tears. So I say again, live well, dear wife. Farewell. Thousand, thousand, the last kisses from your Robert. Written in Vienna on the 9th of November at five in the morning. Oh, at six, it will all be over. So that, Tom Holland, is described as one of the most affecting passages of 19th century German prose by the Regis Professor of History at Cambridge University, Christopher Clarke. And I don't think, Christopher, you've ever heard it read with such feeling, have you?
把我们的、现在只有你一个人的孩子们抚养成人，让他们成为优秀的人。在朋友们的帮助下，卖掉我们为数不多的财产。上帝和善良的人们会帮助你的。哦，我所有的感情都在泪水中流逝。所以我再说一遍，好好活着，亲爱的妻子。再见。千万个、千万个来自你的罗伯特的最后之吻。11月9日清晨五点写于维也纳。哦，六点钟，一切就都结束了。那么，汤姆·霍兰德，这段文字被剑桥大学的历史学教授克里斯托弗·克拉克描述为19世纪德语散文中“最感人的段落之一”。克里斯托弗，我想你以前从未听过有人饱含如此深情地朗读它吧？
I'm still, I'm still drying my eyes. It's wonderful, isn't it? Inspector Clouseau is joined by hair flick. That is, yeah, Tom, that is, that is very cruel. Very cruel. And I think a lot of listeners will be quite shocked at that remark. I think they will. I think they will.
我还在——我还在擦眼泪。这太美妙了，不是吗？克鲁索督察和挥发性发型（Hair Flick）联手了。汤姆，那是——那是相当残忍。非常残忍。我想许多听众听到这个评价会感到相当震惊。我想他们会的。我想他们会的。
But Dominic, yes. So tell us who is talking there. So we were talking about how the the story was going to spread and this is a guy called robert bloom who is the son of a cooper i believe and a seamstress or something like that i can't remember but he had become an apprentice bronze worker and then was a great autodidact and had become a pamphleteer and a poet and a radical german radical who believed in a united, liberal, democratic Germany.
不过，多米尼克，是的。那么告诉我们，刚才说话的人是谁？我们刚才在谈论故事将如何传播，这是一个名叫罗伯特·布鲁姆（Robert Blum）的人，我记得他是一个桶匠和一个女裁缝的儿子，或者类似的情况，我记不太清了。但他后来成为了一名青铜工匠学徒，之后成了一个伟大的自学成才者，并成为了一名小册子作家、诗人和德国激进分子，他坚信建立一个统一、自由、民主的德国。
And his trajectory is he becomes one of the faces of the German revolution in the Frankfurt Parliament. And it all ends in tears for him because he's shot in Vienna, having written this beautiful letter so beautifully read. So his story, Christopher, is the kind of story of what happens to the revolution in microcosm, isn't it? High hopes, heady excitement, liberalism, and then bang, end of story, he's dead. Yes, yes, it is. And for me, Robert Bloom is the kind of human face of the revolution,
他的轨迹是成为了法兰克福议会中德国革命的面孔之一。但对他来说，这一切都以悲剧告终，因为他在维也纳被枪杀，死前写下了这封被如此动人朗读的美丽信件。所以，克里斯托夫，他的故事可以说是微观缩影下革命的写照，不是吗？满怀希望、狂热兴奋，自由主义，然后砰的一声，故事结束，他死了。是的，确实如此。对我来说，罗伯特·布鲁姆可以说是革命的人性化面孔，
because his story captures so much of that move from the extreme euphoria of the spring days. I mean, the revolution, the narrative is complicated, but it's not that complicated. There's a spring, there's a summer, and there's a kind of autumn and winter. And the spring is all about everybody is out on the streets, perhaps on barricades, but perhaps simply marching or taking part in demonstrations. There's an extraordinary sense of euphoria. And I'm thinking here of one account from Berlin, from a young radical law student who says, my heart was beating so hard, I felt it was going to blow a hole in my chest. I had to get out of my room. So he goes out of his sort of student digs, finds himself on the street amongst thousands of people. And he says, I felt I could hear everyone else's hearts beating. This experience, and there's endless testimony to this,
因为他的故事捕捉到了从春日极端狂热中转变的很多东西。我的意思是，革命的叙事很复杂，但也没有那么复杂。有一个春天，有一个夏天，然后有一种秋天和冬天。春天的主题是所有人都走上街头，也许在街垒上，但也可能只是游行或参加示威。有一种非同寻常的狂热感。这里我想到柏林的一个记述，来自一个年轻的激进法学学生，他说，我的心跳得那么厉害，我觉得它要在胸口撞出一个洞。我必须离开房间。于是他离开了那种学生公寓，发现自己身处成千上万人的街头。他说，我觉得我能听到其他所有人的心跳。这种体验——这方面的证言无休无止——
this was an experience of submersion in the collective self, of euphoria, collective euphoria, which people remembered for the rest of their lives. So that's how the revolution starts. Then in the summer comes the kind of breakdown of unity, the fractious disagreements between different bits of the revolution. And Robert Bloom, who's part of that spring moment and travels to the Frankfurt Parliament, first to the pre-parliament and then to the parliament itself in May, is full of high hopes for what's going to happen, this massive work of transformation, which he fray, to come apart. And by the autumn, he's exhausted by it and decides to go to Vienna to bring sort of fraternal greetings to the Viennese parliament. But unfortunately, just as he arrives, the city is surrounded by the Austrian armies and the revolution is crushed in Austria, a very violent process which results in hundreds of dead. And Blum is arrested. And although he pleads parliamentary immunity, he says,
这种体验是沉浸在集体自我中的体验，一种狂热，集体狂热，人们在余生中都铭记着这种体验。这就是革命开始的方式。然后在夏天，出现了那种团结的破裂，革命不同派别之间的激烈争执。而罗伯特·布鲁姆作为那个春日时刻的一部分，在五月前往法兰克福议会，先是到预备议会，然后到议会本身，他对将要发生的事情抱有很高的期望，这是一场巨大的转型工作，结果却走向了解体、分崩离析。到了秋天，他对此感到精疲力竭，决定去维也纳向维也纳议会带去兄弟般的问候。但不幸的是，就在他抵达时，这座城市被奥地利军队包围，革命在奥地利被镇压，这是一个非常暴力的过程，导致数百人死亡。布鲁姆被捕了。尽管他援引议会豁免权，他说，
I'm a member of the Frankfurt Parliament, I have immunity, they say, yeah, whatever, and execute him, as you say, on the 9th of November. And there's a song about this which tells the story of his walk to the place where he was executed. And in the course of this song, the point is made, the observation is made, which we have from several sources, that one of the officers commanding the firing squad noticed a tear rolling down his face
我是法兰克福议会的成员，我有豁免权，但他们说，管你呢，并在你说的11月9日处决了他。有一首歌讲的就是这个故事，讲述了他走向被处决地点的过程。在这首歌的进程中，提出了一个观点，也就是我们从多个消息来源得到的观察，即行刑队的指挥官之一注意到一滴眼泪顺着他的脸颊滚落，
and sort of patted him on the shoulder and said, you know, keine Sorge, Blum, es ist in nur vorüber, something like that. You know, don't worry, old chap, it'll all be over like in a jiffy, right? I don't know if anybody
然后拍了拍他的肩膀说，你知道的，别担心，布鲁姆，这只是一会儿的事，诸如此类的话。你知道的，老兄，别担心，转眼就过去了，对吧？我不知道在那种情况下是否有人
would be comforted by these words in a situation like that, but there you are. And Blum turns to this man and pulls himself up to his full height, which is about five foot four, and says, this tear is not the tear of the parliamentary deputy, Robert Bloom. It's the tear of the father and the husband. So in other words, he insists on his right to experience a private emotion in the middle of this public event. And that tells us something about what a revolution is like in mid-19th century Europe. It means bringing people out of their private lives into public roles, which they've never had before.
会从这些话中得到安慰，但事实就是如此。布鲁姆转向这个人，挺直了腰板，他身高大约五英尺四英寸，然后说：“这滴眼泪不是议会代表罗伯特·布鲁姆的眼泪。这是父亲和丈夫的眼泪。”换句话说，他坚持自己在这一公众事件中体验私人情感的权利。这向我们揭示了19世纪中期欧洲的革命是什么样的。这意味着把人们从他们的私人生活中带入他们从未有过的公共角色中。
I mean, people had to discover their public selves, but they brought their private selves with them into this new public work of revolutionary activism. And he articulates that in this song. And there's a wonderful moment in this song where it says, Die Träne für Weip und Kinder entehret keinen Mann. The tear for one's wife and children does not dishonour a man. That is the ethics, if you like, of a middle-class revolution. I want to go to the barricades after that. Tom is very moved
我的意思是，人们不得不发现他们的公众自我，但他们把私人自我一起带入了这种新的革命激进主义的公共工作中。他在歌中表达了这一点。这首歌里有一个美妙的时刻，歌词唱道：“为妻子和孩子流泪并不辱没一个男人。”为妻子和儿女流泪并不损损一个男人的尊严。如果你愿意的话，这就是中产阶级革命的道德观。听完这些，我都想去筑起街垒了。汤姆对此非常感动，
by that. That was so stirring. That's the best song we've ever had on the podcast, isn't it? We don't really do singing. I mean, we should have more singing. I think the last one was Diamonds are a Girl's Best Friend. Yes, you sang that, but Chris's singing
太感人了。这是我们播客中有史以来最好的歌，对吧？我们其实不怎么唱歌。我的意思是，我们应该多唱唱歌。我想上一首是《钻石是女孩最好的朋友》。是的，你唱了那首，但克里斯的歌声
was, I think it's fair to say, in a very, very different league.. Yes, you sang that. But Chris's singing was in a, I think it's fair to say, in a very, very different league. I'm happy to see that. So Christopher, the people who are in the revolution, are they mainly people like Robert Bloom? In other words,
我觉得可以说是在一个完全、完全不同的水平上。是的，你唱了那首。但克里斯的歌声在——我觉得可以说——在一个完全、完全不同的水平上。我很高兴听到这个。那么克里斯托夫，参与革命的人，主要都是像罗伯特·布鲁姆这样的人吗？换句话说，
are they high-minded, idealistic, young? Well, Dominic, the archetype of that is a guy called Friedrich Hecker. Is that right? Who kind of legal student from Heidelberg, who is, I mean, much more than Blum, seems to be the prototype for Che Guevara. And the idea of revolutionary is romantic, has a famous beard that everyone copies. So just tell us about him, because he seemed a very romantic, I mean, romantic in every sense of the word.
他们是高尚的、理想主义的年轻人吗？嗯，多米尼克，这方面的原型是一个叫弗里德里希·黑克尔的人。是这样吗？他某种程度上是来自海德堡的法律系学生，我的意思是，他比布鲁姆更像是切·格瓦拉的原型。那种革命者的形象是很浪漫的，蓄着每个人都争相模仿的著名胡须。给我们讲讲他吧，因为他看起来非常浪漫，我的意思是，在词的每个意义上都是浪漫的。
Yeah, I mean, Hecker's a fascinating figure, because Blum and Hecker had been very close, and they collaborated and published in the same journals. And, you know, they were part of this radical network that existed in Germany in the 1840s. But Hecker decides that he's had enough of the Exactly. And it's a little bit like, you know, it's also a kind of confusion or a contrast in political timing. So, you know, on the one hand, parliaments are slow, they're ponderous, they're a little bit boring. I mean, sadly, I mean, it's just a fact about parliaments, they're supposed to be boring, and they should be, but they're full of procedural details, and people have to take their time, you time, have to wait their turn to talk. They mustn't speak longer than a certain time and so on. So it's very rule bound.
是的，我是说，黑克尔是一个迷人的人物，因为布鲁姆和黑克尔曾非常亲密，他们曾在同一份期刊上合作和发表文章。而且，你知道，他们是1840年代存在于德国的这个激进网络的一部分。但黑克尔决定他受够了……没错。这有点像，你知道的，这也是政治时机上的一种混乱或对比。所以，一方面，议会是缓慢的、笨拙的、有点无聊的。我的意思是，可悲的是，这就是议会的一个事实，它们本来就应该是无聊的，而且也确实应该是这样的，但它们充满了程序细节，人们必须花时间，你得花时间，必须等待轮到自己发言。他们发言不得超过一定时间等等。所以它是极其受规则约束的。
Whereas Hecker wants to break away from all that and go for direct action. So he sets up this kind of armed insurrection in Baden, which goes horribly, horribly wrong. He wastes a lot of people's lives, doesn't achieve anything. Eventually, he takes another shot at it in the following year, but then flees first to Switzerland and then to the United States, where he later, by the way, plays a role as a commander in the Union Army. So a lot of these people have very interesting afterlives after this moment of 1848. But for Bloom and Hecker, this is a kind of parting of the ways. Hecker represents that violent revolution by direct action, which
然而黑克尔想要摆脱这一切，去搞直接行动。于是他在巴登发动了这种武装起义，结果糟透了，错得离谱。他白白浪费了很多人的生命，什么也没达成。最终，他在第二年又尝试了一次，但随后先是逃往瑞士，然后逃往美国，顺便说一句，他后来在那里扮演了联邦军队指挥官的角色。因此，其中许多人在1848年这个时刻之后都有着非常有趣的人生经历。但对布鲁姆和黑克尔来说，这是各奔东西的分水岭。黑克尔代表了通过直接行动进行的暴力革命，
Bloom believes is doomed to fail. And in fact, the fate of Hecker's escapade shows that Bloom is right. And on the other hand, Bloom remains faithful to the parliament, to this process of discursive debate of discussion, even though he knows, which is hard for a man of the left, he knows that in 1848, the process of election is unlikely to produce a radical majority. You have to work from a minority position and argue for, you know, for pragmatic agreements on particular policies. And that's what Bloom decides to do. So he becomes part of that complicated business of parliament, which Hecker rejects. But it's Hecker who ends up shaping the kind of memory of what it means to be a
布鲁姆认为这是注定要失败的。事实上，黑克尔冒险行动的命运表明布鲁姆是对的。另一方面，布鲁姆仍然忠于议会，忠于这种讨论性辩论的过程，尽管他知道——这对于一个左翼人士来说很难接受——他知道在1848年，选举过程不太可能产生激进多数派。你必须从少数派的立场出发，为特定政策的务实协议进行辩论。这就是布鲁姆决定要做的事情。所以他成为了议会那复杂事务的一部分，而这是黑克尔所拒绝的。但最终塑造了革命者含义的记忆的人却是黑克尔，
revolutionary because he styles, you mentioned Che Guevara before, he's a very vain man. He wears a broad brimmed hat and a long beard, which comes to be known as a Heckerbart, a Heckerbeard, a red sash, baggy trousers tucked into piratical boots, and so on. So he becomes a kind of sexy avatar of revolution, which people find disturbing and yet also perversely attractive. And there are lots of cartoons and caricatures of him. And the interesting thing about him is even when he's being caricatured, he still kind of has a certain raw appeal. A sort of very basic question. So these revolutions in Germany, I mean, Germany tends to end up, I mean, Germany tends to end up,
因为他的风格——你刚才提到了切·格瓦拉——他是一个非常虚荣的人。他戴着宽边帽，留着长长的胡须，后来被称为“黑克尔须”（Heckerbart），系着红腰带，塞进海盗靴里的宽松裤子等等。因此，他成为了一种性感迷人的革命化身，人们对此感到不安，却又有着病态般的吸引力。关于他的漫画和讽刺画有很多。关于他有趣的一点是，即使在被讽刺的时候，他身上仍然有一种原始的吸引力。一个非常基础的问题。所以德国的这些革命，我的意思是，德国往往最终……我的意思是，德国往往最终……
I mean, the German speakers often tend to dominate the accounts of 1848 because you've got what's going on in Germany and then you've got what's going on with Austria and the revolt in Hungary against Austria and so on. But in Germany specifically, are we able to say what they want? So it's because it's there you've got a real combination of socialism, radicalism, liberalism, and nationalism, the idea of a Germany. So is there ever a sort of common, really a common program in Germany, or is it too confused and chaotic for that? Well, it's all happening so fast that people, there's not much time to establish a common program. That's one of the difficulties. And there are lots of tensions between different objectives. So people may share,
我的意思是，讲德语的人往往主导了对1848年的记述，因为你有德国正在发生的事情，然后你又有奥地利正在发生的事情，以及匈牙利针对奥地利的起义等等。但在德国具体而言，我们能否说清楚他们想要什么？因为在那里你真正结合了社会主义、激进主义、自由主义和民族主义，即一个德国的概念。那么在德国，是否存在某种真正的共同纲领，还是说它太混乱、太杂乱无章而没有这个？嗯，这一切发生得太快了，人们根本没有太多时间来建立一个共同纲领。这是困难之一。不同目标之间存在着很多紧张关系。所以人们可能认同，
you know, many radicals like Bloom, for example, believed in parliaments, they thought we do need a parliament, we need the people to be represented through a process of election and so on. We can't just make it up as we go along. On the other hand, they also wanted a social transformation, they wanted the imbalance between labor and capital to be rebalanced, so that people, the poorest strata of society would be better seen to. They'll be in a stronger position to bargain, for example, for improvement in their conditions. And so they were in favor of various forms of trades unions or even of state intervention in the economy to support the working classes, this kind of thing.
你知道的，许多激进分子比如布鲁姆，信仰议会，他们认为我们确实需要一个议会，我们需要人民通过选举等过程得到代表。我们不能随心所欲地凭空捏造。另一方面，他们也想要社会转型，他们希望重新平衡劳动力和资本之间的失衡，以便让社会最贫穷的阶层得到更好的照顾。例如，他们将在更有利的地位上进行谈判，以改善他们的状况。因此，他们赞成各种形式的工会，甚至赞成国家干预经济以支持工人阶级，诸如此类的事情。
But of course, the liberals were what we would today call Thatcherites. They wanted deregulation. They wanted the state to pull back out of the economy. As far as they were concerned, the private character of the economic relationships between people was an almost sacred conviction. And they said the state has no business interfering in the relationship between an employer and an employee. This is a form of tyranny. And these are arguments which have not gone away, incidentally. I mean, they're sharpened by 1848, but they have not left the world. They're still very much at the center of our politics, which is this question of the nation, because there is no German nation state. There are 39 different states, but a German parliament does form. And this is a remarkable thing. It doesn't happen in Italy, but in Germany,
但当然，自由主义者则是我们今天所说的“撒切尔主义者”。他们想要放松管制。他们希望国家从经济中退出。对他们来说，人与人之间经济关系的私人性质是一种几乎神圣不可侵犯的信念。他们说，国家无权干涉雇主和雇员之间的关系。这是暴政的一种形式。顺便说一句，这些争论并没有消失。我的意思是，1848年使它们更加尖锐，但它们并没有离开这个世界。它们仍然非常处于我们政治的中心，也就是国家的问题，因为并不存在一个德国民族国家。有39个不同的邦，但一个德国议会确实形成了。这是一件了不起的事情。这在意大利没有发生，但在德国，
a parliament forms to resolve the future character of a nation that does not exist. I mean, that is an extraordinary state of affairs. Of course, there is no parliamentary building to put this parliament in. So it's put in a church, the St. Paul's Church of Frankfurt, a beautiful round 18th century church, a very fine building. And it's decorated with the red, black and gold tricolour of the German Revolution. And it's there to discuss the affairs of the German nation, of a German nation state that does not yet exist. So what happens? What happens is people come up with endless proposals and disagreements. It's very difficult to get agreements on anything. And of course, it's a little bit like the EU today. While this imaginary Germany is sort of trying to make decisions about its future, that the individual territorial states, Prussia, Saxony, Bavaria, Württemberg, all the rest of the 39 of them have not gone away.
一个议会成立了，以解决一个并不存在的国家的未来性质。我的意思是，这是一种非凡的局势。当然，并没有议会大楼来容纳这个议会。所以它被安置在一座教堂里，法兰克福的圣保罗教堂，一座美丽的18世纪圆形教堂，一栋非常精美的建筑。它用德国革命的红、黑、金三色旗装饰着。它在那里讨论德国民族的事务，一个尚不存在的德国民族国家的事务。那么发生了什么？发生的事情是人们提出了无数的提案和分歧。要在任何事情上达成一致都非常困难。当然，这有点像今天的欧盟。当这个想象中的德国正试图对自己的未来做出决定时，各个领土邦国——普鲁士、萨克森、巴伐利亚、符腾堡，其余39个邦中的每一个——并没有消失。
And they're still making decisions. And in fact, Prussia very much takes the initiative again by the early autumn of 1848 and starts doing deals over issues which are of great importance to the German national movement. And that is one of the things that leads to the collapse of public esteem for and trust in and belief in the parliament at Frankfurt is the fact that Prussia seems to be in a position to defend the interests of the German nation better than the Frankfurt parliament is. After all, the Frankfurt parliament has no army.
它们仍在做出决策。事实上，普鲁士在1848年早秋再次占据了很大程度的主动权，并开始就对德国民族运动具有重大意义的议题进行交易。导致公众对法兰克福议会的声望、信任和信念崩塌的原因之一，就是普鲁士似乎比法兰克福议会有能力更好地捍卫德国民族的利益。毕竟，法兰克福议会没有军队。
It has a tiny sort of shrunken bureaucracy, but it has no means of projecting power or of making people do what it wants them to. So under the pressure of all that sort of powerlessness, it starts to fray and it starts to wane as a presence in people's minds. Just before we come to the backlash, can I ask a question that I know a lot of British reviewers have already commented on? Why not Britain? So in other words, now you will say, you might say, well, there's a big Chartist meeting in Kennington or whatever.
它只有一小撮萎缩的官僚机构，但它没有投射权力的手段，也没有办法强迫人们按它的意愿行事。因此，在所有这种无力感的压力下，它开始分崩离析，在人们心中的存在感开始减弱。就在我们讨论强力反弹之前，我可以问一个我知道很多英国评论员已经评论过的问题吗？为什么不是英国？换句话说，现在你会说，你可能会说，嗯，肯宁顿或其他地方有一个大型宪章派集会。
But I mean, the truth of the matter is 1848 is not a date to conjure with in Britain. And Britain does look in that regard like a bit of an exception. Now, is that too strong or are you going to? No, it's not too strong. It's true. I mean, Britain, there is no revolution on the British mainland or in Ireland, which is where a tumult had also been expected. I mean, Ireland was seen as the most tumultuous part of the United Kingdom. And that is a very interesting and important fact. It's interesting in this connection to read the Sydney Morning Herald down in Australia, where I come from. I come from Sydney. And it's
但我的意思是，事实是1848年在英国并不是一个能引起共鸣的日子。而且英国在这方面看起来有点像个例外。现在，这个说法是不是太绝对了，还是你打算……不，这不算太绝对。这是真的。我的意思是，在英国本土或爱尔兰都没有发生革命，而爱尔兰原本也是一个预计会发生动乱的地方。我的意思是，爱尔兰被视为联合王国中最动荡的部分。这是一个非常有趣且重要的事实。在这个背景下，阅读来自澳大利亚悉尼的《悉尼先驱晨报》很有意思，我就是那里的人。我来自悉尼。而且它
still going strong, the Sydney Morning Herald. But anyway, in the context of 1848, they had to wait a long time to get the news. I mean, it was months and months and months before the news reached Sydney. But when they commented on this, they said, why have things been so quiet in the motherland, meaning Britain, whereas France and Germany and Italy and so on have experienced these sanguinary revolutions? And the good burgers of the Sydney Morning Herald conclude, well, the reason is because when you have colonies, you can take all your troublemakers and push them burgers of the Sydney Morning Herald conclude, well, the reason is because when you have colonies, you can take all your troublemakers and push them out to the skirts of empire, to the outskirts of empire.
现在依然生机勃勃，《悉尼先驱晨报》。但无论如何，在1848年的背景下，他们得等很长时间才能得到消息。我的意思是，消息传到悉尼花了整整几个月的时间。但当他们对此发表评论时，他们说，为什么母国（意指英国）的事情这么平静，而法国、德国和意大利等国却经历了这些血腥的革命？《悉尼先驱晨报》的好市民们得出结论，原因在于，当你拥有殖民地时，你可以把所有的惹事生非者都带走，把他们推向帝国边缘，推向帝国的边缘地带。
In other words, here in Sydney. So we're getting all the troublemakers, the sons of Free Ireland and anybody who's sort of drawn the attention of the police in Ireland winds up in Australia on some kind of transportation charge. So we end up, as it were, bearing the consequences. That's not really the reason, surely. It's part of the reason. There are several reasons. One is, I mean, that Ireland obviously was coming to the end of an absolutely unexampled demographic shock in the form of the Irish famine.
换句话说，就是我们这里的悉尼。所以我们接收了所有的麻烦制造者，自由爱尔兰之子以及任何在爱尔兰引起警察注意的人，最终都带着某种流放罪名来到了澳大利亚。所以我们最终，可以说是承担了后果。这肯定不是真正的原因吧？这是部分原因。原因有几个。一个是，爱尔兰显然正走向一场史无前例的人口冲击的尾声，其形式就是爱尔兰大饥荒。
But Chris, even then, you quote this astonishing thing that the Prussians are sending inspectors to Ireland to see how you repress a revolution. Well, this is another part of the story. See, there are multiple reasons for this. One is, it really is true that the British have been quite good at selecting key troublemakers and moving them out of the zone of trouble, mainly through transportation, partly to Australia and partly to South Africa, to the Cape Colony. And in fact, that practice leads to movements in both those places against the further transportation of convicts. So it's partly that.
但克里斯，即便如此，你还是引述了一件令人震惊的事，普鲁士人正派视察员去爱尔兰看看你们是怎么镇压革命的。嗯，这是故事的另一部分。你看，这有多种原因。一个是，英国人真的很擅长挑选核心麻烦制造者并将他们移出麻烦区，主要是通过流放，一部分去澳大利亚，一部分去南非的开普殖民地。事实上，这种做法导致了这两个地方反对继续流放罪犯的运动。所以部分原因是这个。
It's partly the famine in Ireland, which obviously areas which are suffering from very serious hunger of that kind, we see it elsewhere in Europe as well, don't become active during the revolution because people are just too depleted. And then finally, it's the fact that Britain is the most robustly policed country in Europe by a very large margin. And the Prussians recognize this. And that's why they send in the summer of 1848, they send a fact-finding group to London in the first instance, but then to Dublin, to Cork and other locations to find out what
部分原因是爱尔兰的饥荒，显然，遭受这种极其严重饥荒的地区——我们在欧洲其他地方也能看到这种情况——在革命期间并没有变得活跃，因为人们已经精疲力竭了。最后，事实是英国是欧洲治安防范最严密的国家，遥遥领先。普鲁士人意识到了这一点。这就是为什么他们在1848年夏天派遣了一个实地考察团，首先前往伦敦，然后前往都柏林、科克和其他地方，去查明
are the British getting right? And how can we, the Prussians, get better at policing our own population? Indeed, they do introduce various changes to Prussian policing on the back of what they find out about British policing. So it's a combination of all those different things. And also the fact that Britain is able to keep the price of staple goods down fairly low during 1848 by dismantling the tariff protections of Britain's outlying colonies, places like Jamaica, and or by reducing the fiscal burden of places like Ceylon, for example. And as a result of that, of those measures, those sort of counter, if you like, prophylactic counter-revolutionary measures,
英国人做对了什么？我们普鲁士人怎样才能更好地管理我们自己的国民？事实上，他们确实根据对英国警务的了解，对普鲁士的警务进行了各种改革。所以这是所有这些不同因素的结合。此外，还有一个事实是，英国在1848年期间能够通过取消英国边缘殖民地（如牙买加）的关税保护，或者通过减轻锡兰等地的财政负担，将主食价格保持在相当低的水平。由于这些措施——这些对策，如果你愿意的话，预防性的反革命措施——
you see unrest breakout on several of those peripheral locations. You know, Ceylon has a massive uprising against the structures of British rule in 1848-49. There are peoples in Jamaica and unrest along many other parts of the periphery of the British Empire. So one could say there's a British 1848, just not in Britain. Right. Because you also, I mean, you tell the extraordinary story of British repression of revolution in the Ionian Islands in Greece, so Corfu and so on. Well, that's a fascinating story because, you know, it's a little scatter of seven tiny islands. And the one that's particularly important in 1849 is Cephalonia. And on that island, there is a sort of rural uprising, which is put down with exemplary savagery by the British authorities. And I think it's quite an interesting example, because, you know, when I was at school, we
你会看到其中几个边缘地区爆发了骚乱。（锡兰在1848-49年爆发了针对英国统治结构的巨大起义。）牙买加也有人们起来反抗，在大英帝国边缘的许多其他地方也存在骚乱。所以可以说存在一个英国的1848年，只是不在英国本土。没错。因为你也——我的意思是，你讲了英国在希腊爱奥尼亚群岛（如科孚岛等）镇压革命的非外寻常的故事。嗯，那是一个迷人的故事，因为，你知道的，那是七个小岛组成的散落群岛。其中在1849年特别重要的是凯法利尼亚岛。在该岛上，发生了一种农村起义，遭到英国当局的严厉镇压。我认为这是一个相当有趣的例子，因为，你知道的，当我上学的时候，我们
were told the answer to that question, why wasn't there a revolution in Britain, was that Britain was already so liberal that people's desire for reform was already satiated, thanks to the Glorious Reform Act of 1832, and so on. And the Chartists were, okay, well, they were a movement for reform, not for revolution, and your Chartist was a sensible kind of fellow who would rather go home and have tea with his wife than set fire to someone else's house and this kind of thing. And so those are the arguments that were made,
被告知那个问题的答案——为什么英国没有发生革命——是因为英国已经足够自由，由于1832年光荣改革法案等原因，人们对改革的渴望已经得到满足。而宪章派，好吧，他们是一个争取改革而非革命的运动，你的典型宪章派是一个通情达理的家伙，他宁愿回家和妻子喝茶，也不愿放火烧别人的房子，诸如此类。所以这些就是当时提出的论点，
and it was the liberality of British institutions that saved Britain from revolution. But on the Ionian Islands, we don't see too much liberality. What we see is a lot of flogging and hanging. And in fact, there's a, you know, there's a kind of Europe-wide scandal over how the British handled this uprising in Kefalonia. And so that's an interesting example of, you know, when you actually do see British authorities facing a local tumult of the kind that broke out across the continent. We don't see that they behave more or less as the Austrians and the Prussians and other European states do.
正是英国制度的自由度拯救了英国免于革命。但在爱奥尼亚群岛，我们并没有看到太多的自由。我们看到的是大量的鞭笞和绞刑。事实上，这是一个——你知道的——欧洲范围内关于英国人如何处理凯法利尼亚这场起义的丑闻。所以这是一个有趣的例子，当你真正看到英国当局面临蔓延到整个欧洲大陆的那种本土动乱时。我们看到他们的行为或多或少与奥地利人、普鲁士人和其他欧洲国家一样。
But is there no element of truth to the traditional story that you were taught? I think there is an element of truth. And the element of truth, and it connects that argument about liberality with the argument about policing. And that is that, you know, when the mass meeting on Kennington Common took place that Dominic referred to, there's, you know, the mass meeting of charters. I mean, it was very alarming at the time. People were worried about what would happen. In fact, Metternich, who was on his way out of Europe, fleeing to Britain, stopped in Rotterdam for a few days because they were waiting out the news.
难道你被教导的传统故事里一点真实成分都没有吗？我认为是有真实成分的。真实成分在于，它将关于自由的论点与关于治安的论点联系在了一起。那就是，（当多米尼克提到的肯宁顿公社的大规模集会发生时，你知道，那是宪章派的大规模集会。我的意思是，当时非常令人震惊。人们担心会发生什么。事实上，梅特涅当时正离开欧洲、逃往鹿特丹时，在鹿特丹停留了几天，因为他们在等待消息。）
It rained very heavily, didn't it? I hope so. The rain very heavily, didn't it? The rain stopped play, basically. Which is never a help. But in addition, 80,000 special constables turned up. Including Gladstone. Exactly. And including the future Napoleon III, who'd signed up as a special constable, was hoping to get his hands on some chartists and give them a right drubbing.
雨下得很大，对吧？希望如此。雨下得很大，对吧？雨水基本上制止了游行。这从来没什么帮助。但此外，8万名特别警察出现了。包括格莱斯顿。没错。包括后来成为拿破仑三世的人，他报名当了特别警察，希望能抓到一些宪章派并好好教训他们一顿。
Never got the chance to do that. You know, but there's a commentary by a Tory at the time called Sibthorpe, a sort of ultra-Tory, who says that, you know, by gum, if only those special constables had a chance to get stuck into those chartists, they would have given them such a hiding as no man ever received. And I think he wasn't wrong. I mean, what's special about Britain is it could mobilize, out of its own society, counter-revolutionary forces on a scale which we don't see anywhere else in Europe.
从来没有机会那样做。你知道的，当时有个叫西布索普的保守党人做过评论，那是个极端保守党人，他说，天哪，要是那些特别警察有机会跟那些宪章派大干一场的话，他们会给他们一顿这辈子从没挨过的狠揍。我认为他说得没毛病。我的意思是，英国的特别之处在于，它能从自身的社会中动员起在欧洲其他任何地方都看不到规模的反革命力量。
You know, Giselle can't summon up 80,000 special constables wielding clubs. Because these people are volunteers, right? Yeah. These people are volunteers. Exactly. They're not even paid. They want to get stuck in. Yeah. They're not even paid. They want to get stuck in. So there's a sense in which you have a sufficiently large
你知道的，吉赛尔可召唤不出8万名挥舞着俱乐部的特别警察。因为这些人都是志愿者，对吧？是的。这些人都是志愿者。没错。他们甚至没有薪水。他们就是想加入进来。对。他们甚至没有薪水。他们就是想大干一场。所以某种意义上说，你拥有一个足够庞大的
stakeholding element in the society to come to the defence of the current political order against those who would challenge it. And talking about sort of counter-revolutionaries, so it's a huge canvas to try and cover in just under an hour, but when we get to the sort of late summer, autumn, there is this backlash. Now, do you think that was, you know, the Austrians sending in the troops, the French turn to the guy who becomes Napoleon III and so on and so forth? Do you think ultimately that was inevitable?
利益相关群体，能够为了保护现有的政治秩序挺身而出，对抗那些想要挑战它的人。说到反革命分子，要在不到一个小时的时间里涵盖如此宏大的画卷，但当我们到了夏末、秋季的时候，出现了这种反弹。现在，你认为那是——你知道的，奥地利人派军队进去，法国人转向那个后来成为拿破仑三世的人等等——你认为最终那是不可避免的吗？
I mean, I know historians were never allowed to talk about things being inevitable, but do you think that was always likely to happen, that the forces of counter, of reaction were always too strong, and that the Robert Blooms of this world were never really going to get what they wanted? That's a really interesting question. When you put it like that, was it always going to happen that way? I mean, some of these outcomes are profoundly surprising. I mean, the fact that someone like Napoleon III, well, he's not Napoleon III yet, but the fact that the man who will become Emperor Napoleon III is voted president of the Republic in December 1848,
我的意思是，我知道历史学家从来不被允许谈论事情是不可避免的，但你认为那总是很可能发生的吗？反动的力量总是太强大了，世上的罗伯特·布鲁姆们永远不可能真正得到他们想要的东西？这是一个非常有趣的问题。当你这样提问时，事情是不是注定会那样发展？我的意思是，其中一些结果极其令人惊异。我的意思是，像拿破仑三世这样的人——好吧，他当时还不是拿破仑三世，但那个将在1848年12月被投票选举为共和国总统的人，
which is one of the death blows to the revolutionary movement in Paris and in France as a whole, that's actually a very unexpected and rather odd outcome. Because, you know, in the 1830s and 40s, he'd been a figure of ridicule. So he kind of comes from nowhere from left field. It's a bit like Trump. In fact, in many ways, he is a Trumpian kind of character. So there's nothing inevitable about that. What seemed at the time to be unlikely was the rapid success of the revolutions. So revolutions are, if you like, sequences of very unlikely events. It's unlikeliness following unlikeliness following unlikeliness. And so nothing in a way about any of this was particularly likely. But nevertheless, in retrospect, obviously, it becomes clear that the forces of the ancien
这对巴黎乃至整个法国的革命运动来说是沉重打击之一，这其实是一个非常意想不到且相当奇怪的结果。因为，你知道的，在1830和1840年代，他曾是个笑柄。所以他有点像从左翼的不知名角落里杀出来的。这有点像特朗普。事实上，在许多方面，他就是一个特朗普式的人物。所以这一切并没有什么必然性。当时看起来不太可能的反而是革命的迅速成功。所以革命，如果你愿意的话，是一系列极不可能发生的事件。它是极不可能发生的事紧接着极不可能发生的事，再紧接着极不可能发生的事。所以在某种程度上，这一切都没有特别的必然性。然而回想起来，很显然，旧政权的势力——
regime, which is not really the right term for them, but the forces of order that had been challenged by the revolution, they had cards up their sleeves, more cards up their sleeves than perhaps they seemed to when the revolution was initially in the full flush of its success. They had loyal armed forces. That was one of the most important things. And another sort of a thing that I think they didn't know themselves was they had the support of a surprisingly large part of the population. It seemed during the revolution that the liberals and the radicals are absolutely making the running. All the newspapers, all the pamphlets, all the posters, all the public manifestations were for revolution of one form or another. But what emerged as the revolution began to wane was a sort of backlash of popular conservatism that no one had really known was there. And this is one
这并不是一个真正适合他们的词，但被革命挑战过的秩序力量——他们手里有底牌，比革命最初处于成功全盛时期时看起来更多的底牌。他们拥有忠诚的武装力量。这是最重要的东西之一。另一个他们自己可能都不知道的事情是，他们得到了意想不到的庞大人口的支持。在革命期间，似乎自由派和激进派完全掌握了主导权。所有的报纸、所有的册子、所有的海报、所有的公众游行都是为了某种形式的革命。但随着革命开始衰退，浮出水面的是一种谁也不知道它存在的保守主义大众反弹。这是保守派的重大发现之一，
of the great sort of discoveries for the conservatives that, you know, perhaps it's us. This is what they're saying. Anyway, perhaps we're the ones who really know the little people. Yeah. The revolutions were living in a bubble, in an urban bubble. People like each other. So this is your 1968 parallel, right? That 1968 ends with the election of Richard Nixon and the war in Vietnam continues and all these kinds of things.
你知道的，也许是我们。他们是这么说的。不管怎样，也许我们才是真正了解底层民众的人。是的。革命者生活在泡沫中，生活在城市泡沫中。人们彼此喜欢。所以这就是你的1968年的平行事件，对吧？1968年以理查德·尼克松的当选而告终，越南战争仍在继续，诸如此类的事情。
And, you know, when President de Gaulle calls out the people France, and actually there are more of them than they are of the people throwing cobblestones at the police, right? It's the same story. But in a way, isn't it even more primal than that? That perhaps we think of 1848 as the revolutionary year, but it's also the year that gives birth perhaps to conservatism as a political force in the way that we would understand it now. Absolutely. That's the complexity of 1848, that revolution and counter-revolution are born twins in the same bed. That's the weird thing about 1848. It's a fascinating thing. But of course, counter-revolution, you know, conservatism is not the same as reaction. There are reactionaries who are saying, you know, we've got to unmake this revolution. We've got to
而且，你知道的，当戴高乐将军号召法国人民时，实际上走出来的人比那些向警察投掷鹅卵石的人还要多，对吧？这是同一个故事。但在某种程度上，难道它不比那更原始吗？也许我们认为1848年是革命之年，但它也是孕育保守主义作为一种政治力量（以我们现在理解的方式）的年份。绝对是的。这就是1848年的复杂性，革命和反革命在同一张床上作为双胞胎诞生。这就是1848年奇特的地方。这是一件引人入胜的事情。但当然，反革命——你知道的，保守主义并不等同于反动。有些反动分子在叫喊，你知道，我们必须废除这场革命。我们必须
turn the clock of history back. But they are in a small minority and they all fail. Whereas the conservatives who are going to shape the future are conservatives who've learned from the revolution. So like Bismarck being the classic. Bismarck is a classic example, a man of brilliant intellect who immediately sees this revolution cannot be undone. It's a new point of departure. We've got to live with it. And anyone who tries to resuscitate the pre-revolutionary past is a fool. And throughout his life, he recognized that 1848 was the sort of pivotal moment in his own career. It was the enabling moment that without it, he could never have become
把历史的钟表拨回过去。但他们只是极少数，而且都失败了。而将塑造未来的保守派是从革命中吸取了教训的保守派。就像俾斯麦是个典型的例子。俾斯麦是一个典型的例子，一个才华横溢的人，他立刻看出这场革命是无法被抹杀的。这是一个新的起点。我们必须带着它生活。任何试图让革命前的过去复活的人都是傻瓜。在他的一生中，他都承认1848年是他自己职业生涯的关键时刻。这是一个赋能的时刻，没有它，他绝不可能成为
the person that he became because it was the revolution that allowed him to enter public life. And because it unleashes the power of nationalism, right? Because it creates the idea of the nation as the main vehicle for kind of popular idealism and aspirations and crowds and modernity. Nationalism is modern after 1848, isn't it? Well, that's right. Although Bismarck sees very clearly that nationalism is going to have to be a managed force. It'll have to be managed by a media which is itself carefully managed and overseen. And that's the great lesson of 1848, that nationalism kind of as a free-floating potential in European society is not going to achieve very much. But nationalism, when it's yoked to state power, will achieve enormous amounts. And that's what happens after 1848.
他后来那个人，因为正是革命允许他进入公共生活。并且因为它释放了民族主义的力量，对吧？因为它将民族创造为大众理想主义、追求、民众和现代性的主要载体。民族主义在1848年之后才变得现代，不是吗？嗯，是的。尽管俾斯麦非常清楚地看到民族主义将不得不成为一种被管控的力量。它必须由一个本身受到仔细管理和监督的媒体来管理。这就是1848年的伟大教训，民族主义作为欧洲社会中一种自由浮动的潜力，是不会取得太大成就的。但是民族主义，当它与国家权力结合在一起时，将取得巨大的成就。这就是1848年之后发生的事情。
So lots of the kind of the more radical constitutions and so on get repealed. And to that extent, we could perhaps talk of the ambitions and hopes of the more radical revolutionaries failing. But one of the things that struck me in the book was that actually, there are a number of constitutions in Europe that are still kind of basically current today that do reach back to 1848. So you mentioned Switzerland, I suppose, reached back to 1847, but the Netherlands. And I thought the most interesting one was Denmark, which had been the kind of absolute monarchy and then becomes a kind of model liberal democracy. And that constitution stays in place after 1848.
所以许多更激进的宪法等都被废除了。从这个程度上讲，我们或许可以说更激进革命者的雄心和希望失败了。但书中让我印象深刻的一点是，事实上，欧洲有许多宪法直到今天基本上仍然有效，它们确实可以追溯到1848年。所以你提到了瑞士，我想可以追溯到1847年，还有荷兰。我认为最有趣的是丹麦，它曾是某种专制君主制，然后变成了一种民主自由主义的模范。而那部宪法在1848年后一直保留了下来。
Absolutely. To this day, the Danes still celebrate the day of the promulgation of that constitution, the June Basic Law. So it's, you know, that's just one of many examples of constitutions that still survive today. I mean, the Swiss Constitution of 1848, it's not until 1848 they actually promulgate it, is still in force with many amendments and so on. The Dutch Constitution of 18, the revised Dutch Constitution of 1849, which comes about as a result of the 1848 revolutions, those revisions are still in place. And, you know, in many ways, these, the Italians too, the Italian constitution winds up being the Piedmontese constitution. The Piedmontese constitution is issued in March 1848, the Statuto Albertino, and it too survives and bits of its language are still present in today's Italian constitution. And so are bits of the German constitution of 1848. They're still present in the Grundgesetz
绝对是的。直到今天，丹麦人仍在庆祝该宪法颁布的日子，即六月基本法。所以，你知道，这只是今天仍然存在的众多宪法中的一个例子。我的意思是，1848年的瑞士宪法——直到1848年他们才真正颁布它——在经过许多修正案等之后仍然有效。1848年革命带来的荷兰18世纪——修订后的1849年荷兰宪法，这些修订至今仍然有效。而且，你知道，在许多方面，这些——意大利也是如此，意大利宪法最终变成了皮埃蒙特宪法。皮埃蒙特宪法于1848年3月颁布，即《阿尔贝托法典》（Statuto Albertino），它也幸存下来，其语言的碎片仍然存在于今天的意大利宪法中。1848年德国宪法的碎片也是如此。它们仍然存在于今天的德意志联邦共和国基本法中。因此，在这些革命过程中取得的巨大成果确实经受住了时间的考验并得以幸存。我们真的没有时间去探讨它，但你也认为现代当代天主教也可以追溯到这个时期。那也是一个迷人的故事。天主教教会——我们没有时间讲那个了，但它必须彻底重塑自己。它确实在1848年之后做到了这一点。而我们认为是天主教教会的大部分内容，实际上正是诞生于那个时刻。你最后的台词是，你基本上说，当我们回顾过去时，我们不应该看到我们自己。我的意思是，我想你基本上是说，
of today's German Federal Republic. So a huge amount of what was achieved in the course of these revolutions did stand the test of time and did survive. We haven't really got time to touch it, but you also argue that modern contemporary Catholicism dates back to this time as well. That's another fascinating story. The Catholic Church, we don't have time for that, but it has to completely remake itself. And it does in the aftermath of 1848. And most of what we think of as the Catholic Church is actually born in that moment. And your last lines, so you basically say, we're not supposed to see ourselves when we look back in the past. I mean, I think so you basically say, we're not supposed to see ourselves
当我们回顾过去时，我们不应该看到我们自己。我的意思是，我想汤姆和我完全同意这一点。然而，有趣的是，你认为1848年的革命者能在我们身上看到他们自己。所以你发现当时与现在的共鸣非常惊人。我发现它们非常惊人。我想在那个结束评语中表达两点。一是，你知道，共鸣是存在的。你越是去思考它们，它们就越多，也越显得有说服力。第二点是，那些过去的人很聪明。我们很容易把过去的人看作是带着有缺陷的计划等的怪人，尤其是当他们的计划没有实现时。
when we look back in the past. I mean, I think Tom and I would completely agree with that. However, intriguingly, you think the revolutionaries of 1848 could see themselves in us. So the resonances between then and now you find very striking. I find them very striking. And I wanted to say two things with that closing comment. One is that, you know, the resonances are there. And the more you think about them, the more there are and the more persuasive they seem. And the second thing is that those people were smart. It's easy to think of people in the past as crackpots with flawed schemes and so on, especially when their schemes don't come off.
但实际上，他们是极其深思熟虑和聪明的人。他们至少和我们一样聪明。他们在思考未来。所以他们在思考我们。我的意思是，尽管他们不认识我们每一个人——这对他们来说很遗憾——但无论如何，他们确实在思考未来。而且他们是以一种非常有趣、充满冒险精神且——你知道的——在智力上足智多谋的方式在这样做。这也是这场革命真正的迷人之处之一，它就像一个狂野的实验实验室。这就是为什么我认为它值得我们今天去关注。这也是为什么这本书确实是对一种言论的驳斥
But actually, they were incredibly thoughtful and intelligent people. They were at least as smart as us. They were thinking about the future. So they were thinking about us. I mean, even though they didn't know us individually, sadly for them, but nevertheless, they were thinking about the future. And they were doing that in a very interesting, adventurous, and, you know, intellectually resourceful way. And that's one of the real fascinations of this revolution, that it was like a kind of wild experimental laboratory. And that's why I think it repays our attention today. And that's why the book really is an attempt to refute a comment
但实际上，他们是极其深思熟虑且聪明的人。他们至少和我们一样聪明。他们在思考未来。所以他们在想我们。我的意思是，尽管他们并不认识我们个人，对他们来说很遗憾，但尽管如此，他们确实在思考未来。而且他们以一种非常有趣、充满冒险精神且智识充沛的方式在这样做。这也是这场革命真正的魅力所在，它就像一个疯狂的实验实验室。这就是为什么我认为它值得我们今天关注，这也是这本书真正试图反驳某种言论的原因
made by a very beloved teacher, actually, a history teacher at school, who announced that when we were doing 1848, he said to us, boys, the 1848 revolutions are complicated and they're a failure. And I remember thinking that's a very unattractive combination. And the book really documents my discovery of how wrong that is. I mean, it's not entirely wrong. They are complicated, but they're not a failure. And they're very, very interesting. Brilliant. Well, the book is Revolutionary Spring, Fighting for a New World, 1848 to 1849. It's a
实际上是由学校一位非常受爱戴的老师，一位历史老师制作的，他在我们学习1848年历史时宣布，他对我们说，孩子们，1848年的革命很复杂，而且它们失败了。我记得当时觉得这是一个非常没有吸引力的组合。这本书真正记录了我发现这种看法是多么错误的过程。我的意思是，它并非完全错误。它们确实很复杂，但它们并不是失败。而且它们非常非常有趣。太棒了。这本书就是《革命之春：为新世界而战，1848年至1849年》。这是一本
huge book, but enormously readable. And I can't recommend it enough. Tom, you enjoyed reading it, didn't you? I really did. As my Twitter followers will know, I quoted vast chunks of it. Really great. So Christopher, thank you so much for joining us. Thank you for enduring Tom's shocking French accent in the first half. And Dominic's, I mean, appalling German accent. Well, I think, no, no. Christopher agreed that you were very harsh on it. No, I was deeply moved by both performances.
厚重的书，但极具可读性。我极力推荐它。汤姆，你读得很开心吧，对吗？我真的很喜欢。正如我的推特粉丝所知，我引用了其中的大量片段。真的很棒。克里斯托弗，非常感谢你加入我们。谢谢你忍受了汤姆在上半场令人震惊的法语口音。还有多米尼克的，我是说，惨不忍睹的德语口音。嗯，我想，不，不。克里斯托弗同意你们对他的批评太严厉了。不，我对这两种表演都深受感动。
Thank you. Well, you did a bit of singing yourself, which is always good on the rest is history. Do you have a revolutionary song from 1848 that you could take us out with? Well, yes, there's a nice one that the poet Freilichkart did in the form of a translation of Robbie Burns' song, For All That. A man's a man for all that. He translated it into really beautiful German, and it's really one of the loveliest songs of 1848.
谢谢。好吧，你自己也唱了一小段，这在《历史剩余》节目中总是很好的。你有什么1848年的革命歌曲可以让我们在歌声中结束吗？是的，有一首很好的，是诗人弗赖利格拉特以翻译罗伯特·彭斯的歌曲《管他那一套》（For All That）的形式创作的。男子汉大丈夫，管他那一套。他把它翻译成非常优美的德语，这确实是1848年最可爱的歌曲之一。
Take it away. Thank you very much. Goodbye, everyone. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
请开始吧。非常感谢大家，再见，各位。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史剩余》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听权限、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐剩余》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。